hunger
there's nothing better how hungry are
you
how much do you really want it
be proud of your hunger do that suppress
your ambition it is a good thing
build the biggest thing you can build do
not tear down other people's projects
that do not be embarrassed of wanting to
build the biggest project of them all
in that and if you can accomplish it you
will bring so much joy and happiness you
will create a blueprint for others you
will help so many people do not suppress
your hunger do not allow anybody to tell
you it is wrong do not tell them or let
excuse me
anybody tell you that you're dreaming
too big too high have practicality in it
deploy patience in it understand the
audacity of it do not be exposed for the
lack of knowledge of the complexity of
it the grandness of it and what you're
asking for
do not look delusional understand it
learn it nurture it respect it and
understand that you understand that if
you are one of the lucky few that was
given enormous ambition and hunger it is
a power that can drive you all the way
through but please reconcile that and
understand how to corral it with
kindness
kindness is the great equalizer
- ambition that allows it to become
palpable and will create for people to
cheer for you along the way not not
enjoy your downfalls your micro
downfalls which you will have
the peace my friends understand that
ambition will get you there is the fuel
of success and when mixed with empathy
and the respect of merit and kindness
and when you can respect your ambition
more than your own short-term wants and
needs you can enable it to take you so
far I laugh I laugh at the outside
judgment of my success and I mean in
both directions
I thank thanks so many of you that think
it's there but I laugh because I know
how much greater it will be because I
understand what my parents and my
circumstance did for me take very little
very little and understanding I was I
did not manipulate my ambition I did not
create my kindness just a product of
but for those of you that are watching
me who watched me you stumbled on the
virality of this video protect your
ambition
it is absolutely fundamentally one of
your secret sauces but please do not let
ambition cloak and trick you into
thinking you can do the wrong things
your ambition does not need to be
fulfilled at the expense of others in
fact when harnessed properly your
ambition should inspire and help so many
please think about your legacy your
teens in your 20s and their 30s and your
40s and please if you are in your 50s
and 60s understand the circumstances of
technology have created a format for you
to exploit and enjoy and it is not too
late for you to rekindle your
diminishing ambition that has been
quelled by the practicalities of your
life that your phone and the
distributions
but the modern-day platforms name
YouTube and Instagram and LinkedIn and
podcasting create an opportunity for the
next three decades of your life darkness
your dwindling ambition and take it to
the next level to the starting points
some of your ambitions are life support
and modern technology that you demonize
for its shortcomings are actually the
anecdote and the potion to create
happiness that you can achieve and some
of you are struggling with your ambition
and your ambition gets the best of you
and your insecurities mixed with your
ambition are allowing you to treat
others poorly and allowing you to spend
money and create circumstance for you to
fake paint a fake picture on social
networks how much success you have and I
promise you that history and the Smart
View understand and feel bad for you but
are cheering for you
legacy and the human race and the
winners that see so clearly today are
reading for you and hoping that you come
across a song a column a video a movie a
piece of communication that gives you
the strength to create a framework and a
blueprint and a guiding North Star of
who you want to be
and who you want to be remembered for I
cheer for you both the opposite sides of
the spectrum the youth and the people
that have been tricked into thinking
they're limited talking to all your
forces nine-year-olds and shed some of
you twenty eight year-olds please please
harness your ambition and mold it into
the incredible thing that it can be the
driving force to the happiness